jojo was geht hier zur markt und
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ihr bestimmt mitbekommen dass ich in
meinem letzten video eine e-mail gezeigt
habe wohl jemand nicht erpresst hatten
gedroht hat meine adresse zu
veröffentlichen und im zuge dessen habe
ich mir ein paar gedanken gemacht was
daran vielleicht nicht so schön ist
youtuber zu sein
generell muss man sagen die youtuber
haben echt glückliches los wir haben
viele möglichkeiten die uns durch
zuschauer gegeben sind ich glaube ich
kann definitiv für alle youtuber
sprechen und sagen dass wir verdammt
dankbar sind aber es gibt auch wirklich
ein paar sachen die man wahrscheinlich
nicht so sieht oder die nicht so
thematisiert werden und deshalb dachte
ich mir ich hau mal fünf youtuber an und
fragt sie was sie am youtuber seinen
persönlich stört so ich fange erst mal
selbst an
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht sobald
leute wissen dass du ein youtuber bist
wirst du direkt komplett schamlos
gefragt was verdienst du also ist es
nicht wie bei keine ahnung dem zahnarzt
und einem lehrer oder so sondern die
leute fragen mich einfach direkt was
verdienst du also keinen kein bisschen
respekt ich meine fragt ihr jemanden der
gerade kennengelernt hat das verdienst
du also wirklich die leute fragen nach
konkreten summen so häufig ist es
einfach verrückt ich meine das ist eine
sache die man nicht wirklich mache man
youtuber ist und da das natürlich so ein
bisschen interessant ist und keine
öffentlichen einblicke gewährt werden
fragt jeder sofort dass und ich finde es
ein bisschen stören weil das ist einfach
so eine sache die man nicht fragt macht
habe mich gerade gefragt was mich auf
youtube ankotzt und es sind auf jeden
fall diese youtuber die e mail richtig
gerne sich einer doppelmoral hohe dass
jemand es sind auf jeden fall die
youtuber die sich richtig gern einer
doppelmoral bedienen spricht einladen an
kleinen sie würden irgendwann nach
machen irgendwelche plagiats vorwürfe
erheben und im endeffekt gar nicht
besser sind mich steuer meisten youtuber
da sein dass es teilweise so viel zeit
in anspruch nehmen gerade wenn man
nebenbei noch was anderes macht also
immer noch
studiert oder wenn man nebenbei arbeitet
dann ist es einfach so unfassbar
zeitintensiv bis zum ende einfach so
viel zeit dass zum beispiel das
privatleben ziemlich viele oder leidet
wenn weniger zeit mit freunden
auszugehen weniger feiern zu gehen und
das finde ich ein bisschen schade
mich nervt im youtuber da sein einfach
dass man nie irgendwie im recht machen
kann also egal was du machst irgendwie
fällt es immer nicht und deswegen habe
ich so lange die einstellungen so dass
man einfach kein klick gibt auf
irgendeine meinung erfreuten uns über
die positiven kommentare aber wenn
irgend welche negativen kommentare da
sondern blendet man das einfach komplett
aus weil man kann es wirklich niemandem
komplettrechner irgendein gibt's immer
da irgendwas kritisiert und ist dann
halt den scheiß egal was mich im youtube
dasein stört ist dass man nicht immer
das zurückbekommen was man reinsteckt
beispielsweise den algorithmus und die
trends seite sind viele videos die
inhaltlich oder qualitativ nicht auf
demselben niveau sind wie manche die man
selbst produziert viel erfolgreicher und
das ist etwas das mich sehr stört dann
an youtuber da sein was mich halt abfall
was ich auch schon auf mit erlebt habe
ist dass leute wirklich zur privatsphäre
nicht akzeptieren einfach so bis vor die
haustür mitgehen bei einigen leuten und
einfach immer noch den namen rufen also
natürlich kann man da die polizei rufen
oder einfach sagen sie ja ich mache das
hier nicht aber einfach dass leute das
mal in den kopf rein kriegen sollten
dass wir menschen sind und nicht
irgendwelche spaß dies dann frag mich
auf jeden fall noch auf das ständig alle
auch die goldwaage gelegt werden muss
wenn ich zum beispiel sagen coca cola
schmeckt lecker war nicht 300.000
kommentare dass ich von coca cola
gekauft bin obwohl ich absolut coca cola
lecker findet das ist so ein paar dinge
die mich manchmal nicht an kosten sonst
alles cool und dann kanal stört mich
dieser tracks content pack erlassen da
braucht es ein letzte sache die mich
noch an youtuber sein stört ist die neue
leute kennenlernt fragen sie sich wie
ich am anfang schon gesagt habe meistens
erst mal wie viel du verdienst und
zweitens bist du ab dem zeitpunkt wo die
leute wissen dass youtube macht nur noch
der youtuber also ich habe schon auf die
erfahrung gemacht dass dann nur darüber
geredet wird
und ja generell das reden du musst allen
leuten jederzeit überall immer sagen was
du auf youtube machst und es ist
einerseits cool dass man da viel darüber
reden kann aber andererseits ist auch
einfach eine sache die glaube ich ihn
andere youtuber auch so geht man redet
und redet und redet und redet über
youtube wenn man neue leute kennenlernt
das ist einfach verrückt so nochmal in
dem seine großes dankeschön
alle youtuber die mir klipp geschickt
haben ja ihr könnt ja immer die
kommentare schreiben sind das sachen die
ich als zuschauer überraschen oder
findet ihr manche sachen gar nicht so
schlimm
lasst mich das einfach wissen das was
vom heutigen video und bis zum nächsten
mal
hieraus wächst